le 15 du Trèfle la tour pour la Coupe du
monde de rugby c'est dans quelques mois
en coulisses on s'active pour faire de
cet accueil à un événement touristique
et économique une délégation de la
Chambre de Commerce et l'Industrie de
Touraine était en visite à Dublin il y a
quelques jours on en parle avec mon
invité Philippe Roussy bonjour bonsoir
vous êtes le président donc de la
Chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
Touraine à l'initiative de ce voyage de
travail et on va le voir sur les photos
qu'on a récupéré un peu de ce voyage
auprès de l'ambassadeur des membres du
monde économique de Dublin du monde
sportif aussi on voit ce kakemono vers
la Touraine est fière d'accueillir
l'équipe d'Irlande de rugby le message
est bien passé là-bas oui il est passé
il est passé avec les officiels bien
évidemment un peu moins avec le grand
public mais avec les officiels il est
bien passé je sais pas si vous avez fait
attention sur la photo il y a le
français l'anglais et le gaeli c'est
important c'est bien ça c'est le sens de
l'accueil de la Touraine qu'est-ce qui
peut ressortir de ce type de d'opération
de Rapp franchement déjà la première
chose c'est quand on accueille une
équipe dans un événement mondial comme
la Coupe du monde de rugby et en plus
l'équipe numéro une mondiale il est
important de bien les accueillir donc
c'est important de se faire connaître
c'est important qui nous connaissent qui
connaissent le territoire c'est
important qu'ils connaissent ce monde
économique parce que nous on y va aussi
pour ça et on a eu des très bons
contacts et les Irlandais sont très
accueillants l'idée pour vous c'est de
tisser ses liens économiquement avec
avec Dublin avec cet environnement
économique local l'idée c'est de avec un
contact physique de commencer à pouvoir
se dire qu'on a des choses à faire
ensemble c'est à dire c'est le début
d'une aventure on n'est pas là pour dire
que une fois que la Coupe du Monde sera
finie on arrêtera de travailler avec
Fernande on est là pour créer quelque
chose qui n'existe pas aujourd'hui c'est
à dire que il y a aucun lien
concrètement il y a très peu de liens il
y a très très peu de liens il y a un peu
de lien entre la France et l'Irlande
mais avec notre région il y en a très
peu et quel est l'atout que peut avoir
tout ou la Touraine dans dans ces liens
économiques avec le tourisme déjà en
termes de tourisme la agriculture
puisque c'est des choses qu'on a discuté
avec eux aussi ça les intéresse ils sont
très bières mais en fait la culture du
vin va les intéresser aussi donc on aura
un sujet sur la viticulture sur le
tourisme les châteaux et puis après de
manière générale il y a deux secteurs
d'activité le digital qui où ils sont
très forts évidemment puisque tous les
sièges européens des grandes entreprises
américaines sont à Dublin donc ça des
sièges européens de tous les gafams
pour eux et puis tout ce qui est santé
biomédicalement les biotechnologies
c'est des choses où ils sont assez faux
de la Touraine évidemment tout à fait
donc ça veut dire que derrière il y aura
aussi des rencontres de chefs
d'entreprise qui vont venir peut-être
aussi alors pour l'instant c'est encore
trop tôt pour le dire mais on a créé des
liens avec novailles aussi Dick et le
l'incubateur de start-up de de
l'Université du blind donc on va les
mettre en relation avec l'Université de
Tours et derrière on va essayer de les
inviter à un événement qui qui va
arriver assez vite puisque le 2
septembre on aura et ça c'est une
confirmation
que je peux donner puisqu'on l'a eu avec
les refus avec la Fédération de
d'Irlande ils ont calé leur entraînement
libre le 2 septembre donc ça veut dire
que le 2 septembre à Tours les
Tourangeaux supporters enfin tout le
monde pourra assister à l'entraînement
de l'équipe d'Irlande de rugby c'est ça
logiquement oui si rien n'est changé
d'ici là je peux pas en dire plus
aujourd'hui l'information que j'ai c'est
celle-ci bon bah on note bien sur les
tablettes de septembre entraînement
équipe de de
d'Irlande de rugby vous avez vu
justement ces
représentants de la Fédération du rugby
d'Irlande
tour les inspires et ils ont hâte de
venir qu'est-ce qui vous savez il y a eu
un très beau travail de l'association
tour rugby 2023 2024 que nous épaulons
bien évidemment avec Bertrand Bourgeot
et avec la fols c'était avec nous donc
c'est un dirigeant d'entreprises aussi
qui connaît bien le monde du rugby et il
a vraiment travaillé ils ont ils ont eu
des réunions de travail pendant la
période où on était là-bas pour voir un
peu comment ils envisagaient notamment
le travail de la musculation dans la
salle on a tous les équipements
maintenant mais voir si on a encore des
choses adaptées il y avait alas au Call
of Duty qui est la directrice de Belmont
qui va accueillir le liquide donc il y a
eu des travaux avec les agences de
voyages donc franchement on est on est
en train de tisser des liens avec avec
l'IRFU avec tous secteurs économiques
irlandais on sait toujours pas j'imagine
c'est encore flou le nombre d'Irlandais
qui viendront en Toral en Touraine faut
pas s'attendre d'avoir des dizaines de
milliers de supporters irlandais on
n'est pas un stade il y a pas de match
donc par contre on aura certainement
quelques centaines de supporters c'est
un sport où on suit vraiment les équipes
en plus c'est les numéros un donc si on
se fait un bon travail de d'approche
avec l'Irlande on doit pouvoir avoir
quelques centaines si 70 personnes le
staff rien que le staff c'est 70
personnes avec l'équipe il y aura des il
y aura des médias internationaux c'est à
dire que l'équipe d'Irlande étant la
numéro une tous les médias mondiaux vont
venir à Tours pour voir comment ça se
passe dans l'équipe d'Irlande pendant la
coupe du monde donc juste ça plus c'est
supporters on aura forcément une
activité économique liée à cette
présence merci beaucoup Philippe aussi
d'être passé dans notre journal pour se
débrief donc de ses relations France
irlandaise et tout ranjo du blé noir
merci à vous